[Music]  we're taking The Late Late Show across  the pond James Corden brings the Late  Late Show to his hometown in London and  he's putting ed Sheeran in the hot seat  in a new carpool karaoke sneak peak well  we can't wait to see the pair belt out  more of Sharon's hits during the  upcoming segment something happens in  that couple that's never happened before  it comes as no surprise that Ed's rap  skills are on fire remember when the  singer nailed this cover of The Fresh  Prince of bel-air theme song I was  sephora cabin when it came near the  license plate said fresh Amaya Dyson to  me and anything I could say that this  cab  whoever thought now forget it yo Holmes  bel-air  [Music]  you